Welcome to Ear Biscuits.
The podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
I'm Link.
This week at the round
table at dim lighting,
we are fielding your pressing questions
and having what is sure to be
a fun, loving conversation.
Maybe pressing your fielding questions.
Remember Field & Stream, the magazine?
I remember the cover.
It's not like I ever-
You didn't get it?
Subscribed to it.
I for some reason, I
would get it occasionally.
Really?
Yeah.
You weren't a subscriber, but
you would randomly get it.
I would buy it off of the shelf.
It was also-
I don't know why because
I was like I like field
and I like streams.
It's fishing and hunting.
Hunting and fishing,
and I did that as a kid.
We're gonna answer questions including,
would we be friends if we met as adults.
How long should you wait before you honk
at someone who's not going in
front of you on a green light.
Those are two different questions.
They're very much related.
I don't know how.
Is there a magazine that you would pick up
off of the shelf?
A magazine that I would pick up,
Entertainment Weekly.
That was the magazine-
As a child?
As a middle schooler, and
maybe even a high schooler.
My brother subscribe
to Sports Illustrated.
You're gonna talk about the
swimsuit issue, aren't you?
The swimsuit issue-
If you bring up Sports Illustrated, I-
Speaking of Field & Stream-
I distinctly remember
you showing up to school.
I brought it to school?
No, you didn't bring it,
but you brought a report
about it, and not for class.
Just for me.
Well, I don't know exactly
what my parents were-
My brother got Sports
Illustrated swimsuit issue.
I don't know what year the
swimsuit issue came out first.
Well he got all the issues.
That's only when you talked about.
I don't know which one came out first,
but I don't know.
The first year, the swimsuit issue,
but I guess that's irrelevant.
When it first came out,
it was illustrated.
All the sports were illustrated-
Even the swimsuit issue was illustrated,
which just had the same effect.
Yeah, it was basically
like a coloring book.
Which we have one of
those now, spoiler alert.
It's the one which Kathy Ireland on it.
She now sells home goods.
She has a line at Target.
The math adds up for that.
Man, well, I don't partake of
the swimsuit issue anymore.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like, I'm aware of it,
in the way that you're
aware of it on the internet,
and you're like, oh-
It was a big deal.
This woman is on the front.
Everybody knows who's on the front,
but back in the day it
was like, well, of course,
I'm gonna spend some time on the front,
but I'm going in.
I'm gonna spend way too much time-
Well, did you take it in secret?
Did Cole know you were
taking it from his room?
Your parents certainly
didn't know that he had it.
No, they did because my
mom would get the mail.
I think it was... I mean,
again I'm just going off of
pure conjecture at this point,
but my mom is the one
who collected the mail.
I think that she may
just made the decision,
well, he subscribes to this.
That doesn't seem like...
Given the environment and
the amount of oversight...
Well, maybe oversight
is not the right word.
It was just a woman in a bikini.
You know what I'm saying, it wasn't porn.
No, but it seemed
scandalous to us to have it.
I wouldn't be caught dead looking at it
in the aisle or the shortstop.
That'd be embarrassing.
Well there's more
embarrassing things than that.
Well, certainly,
but I just think that we
had a little bit too much.
I had a little bit too much shame.
Still do apparently.
Yeah, ding, ding, ding moment.
I'm just kidding.
I mean a lot of-
We've all gotten shame there.
A lot of them you'd could see
more than a bathing suit show.
Well, I mean, especially back in the day.
Back in the day.
I mean that's like just everybody.
Your teacher wears that
kind of bathing suit now.
On her TikTok account.
Do teachers have TikTok now?
I don't even wanna know.
Yeah, a teacher TikTok.
It's a whole section.
Teacher Tok.
I took a trip to Joshua Tree.
Look at me, man.
I come back from Zion,
and then weeks later-
Back from the desert.
Here I am going back to another
national park desert location.
Did you know that Joshua Tree did not
become a national park until 1994?
Yeah, after the U2 album.
That's when they sent the
government over the edge.
Bill Clinton was like,
I've got to get this place taken care of.
We've gotta protect this place.
We gotta protect this place, we really do.
I had a conversation with Bono.
This is how I had a
conversation with Bono.
He finally returned my calls when I said
I was gonna make Joshua
Tree a national park.
He called me back, and
Edge was in the background.
What year was that album released?
I don't know.
I am not a U2 fan, you know that.
Our friend, Mike, took
you to a U2 concert.
Yeah.
I mean, I respect...
You know I say, I respect U2.
We have very similar tastes in music.
I think the reason why we don't like U2,
or haven't gotten into U2 it's like,
it's more about us than it is about U2.
Really?
I think, yeah.
I think it's about U2, it's not about me.
It's a little... Because just like-
It's a little too rocky for us.
A little too rocky.
A little too rocky, we
like a little more soul.
Even when it gets pensive,
it's still a little too rocky for us.
There's something about that.
We never connected with just pure rock.
Never got into it.
I always felt like it wasn't for us.
It's like rap, yeah.
Country, yeah.
Soul, yeah.
Rock, southern rock, yeah, rock...
Classic rock, yeah, but like-
Some classic rock, yeah, CCR?
We're getting it out
of U2, so I don't know.
I think there's people who would try to...
I'm pretty sure there's a
Joshua Tree on the album.
On the cover people will try to find it.
Yeah, and that's not-
We can't because I mean,
you see one Joshua Tree,
you've seen them all.
Well they're all different.
They're just like Netflix, I know.
But it never snows where Joshua Trees are,
which is a mind-blowing thing.
Also not true, also not
true, I don't think.
You can have some snow at Joshua Tree.
It's like a high desert
and a lower desert meet,
and this Joshua Trees have
Same amount of elevation.
They're very specific because even
when we would do an
offloading, over landing trip,
like when we went to Death
Valley for those three
or four nights.
I remember we'd go into this
one valley or crest this hill.
It was only in one place,
and we were in this expansive valley.
You lose perspective when
you're driving through
Death Valley, about how...
What altitude you're at.
What elevation you're at.
You're not flying, but
what elevation you're at.
If you've got a good spoiler.
Sometimes you might think, oh,
we've been in this valley for a long time,
and then you round another
corner and there's just...
It was just an inlet to
a much more huge valley
because everything gets so expansive.
I remember coming around over one ridge,
and all of a sudden it was
just Joshua Trees everywhere.
We've been driving for a couple of days,
and it was only in this one place.
It was one altitude,
but Joshua Tree special
because they're so many
there at that particular...
I keep meaning to say elevation.
Did you go to the...
I can't remember the name of it,
but there's a forest of
a certain type of cactus
that you can walk through.
No.
It's incredibly, densely...
It's the thing that if
you are playing around
and you pushed your friend,
they would get a bunch of needles in them.
You have to watch where
you're walking, but it's just.
Did you go there?
Yeah, I've been there twice now.
No, but to this particular
place you're talking about.
It's one of the stops
off of the main road,
if you're going through Joshua Tree.
I haven't but that is the thing-
It's called the so-and-so forest,
and it's just these cacti-
I didn't even see-
That are like this tall.
It's pretty remarkable.
You should have told me that a week ago.
It's the most unlike
the rest of Joshua Tree,
but it's not as cool as
the rest of Joshua Tree.
You're not missing much
but it's just unusual.
Well, the thing about
Joshua Tree, you're right.
There's basically one paved road
that goes through Joshua Tree.
There's some offshoots but not many.
It's pretty Disneyesque in that way.
Yeah, and so you'll go to one parking lot,
and then you'll take the loop trail
with whatever rock features
are associated with that.
Then you get back in the car
and you'll drive to another place.
We had the kids.
It was just a family excursion,
and we stayed in an Airbnb.
Too many people for a van.
That's a problem I have.
I'm still obsessing about
this van life on Instagram,
but Insta-cramming my family
into a van is a bit much.
We have one too many kids.
What about van life meets trailer life?
It's a van and you haul
a trailer and their kids
are in the trailer, a
windowless trailer behind you.
I mean, Lily's getting to the age,
she's going off on her own.
I'm just thinking that she's
just not part of the equation.
If I were to get one of these vans,
it would be like, take a kid or two.
Take a wife or two, but
not take everybody at once.
I get it.
I mean, I can take Christie
and Jesse is what I'm saying.
Well, Jesse likes to do things on her own.
With me and Christie.
You're saying, Jesse likes
to do things without you.
She can do whatever she wants, man.
You know what, we give
each other lots of freedom.
Something about your response
rings of a reprimand that you've gotten
from Jessie about something
you've talked about.
No, I'm just joking.
I mean, she really,
she went on a solo trip
that she really enjoyed.
That's our thing now.
We just go on separate trips.
You alternate.
Whose weekend is it to be
away from the other person?
This was her first too.
Just once.
Just maybe annual road trip
each person gets there
because I feel like,
if only one person in the couple is on...
In fact, we were asked
this question in the AMA
on the medical society today.
Somebody was asking, how do
I talk my significant other
into me going on a solo trip.
I was like, I didn't
have to worry about that
because Jesse and I were
both making the decision
to prioritize a solo trip
independently at the same time.
Yeah, the answer is-
You gotta both be onboard.
Get them to go on one first.
They had to see it as not being about them
but being about you.
The solo trip-
What do you mean?
The solo trip has nothing to do
with me getting away from Jessie.
The solo trip has everything to do with me
having time with myself, and
her having time with herself
so we can come back and be
better people in general,
which benefits the other person
and the rest of the family.
How's that going, by the way?
The benefiting of the other people?
No, are you a better person?
Is it worn off?
I would say, I think he take...
You just Paula Abdul.
I think I Paula Abdul-ed it.
One step forward two steps back?
I thought it was two steps
forward and one step back.
Did she say two steps...
One step forward and two steps back?
Two steps forward, two steps...
I think it's two and two now that I-
Well, then what the hell does Paula do?
Opposites attract.
She's taking two steps forward
and that person's taking two steps back?
It ain't fiction, it's a natural fact.
Two step forward-
She wasn't even talking
about the same thing
that I'm talking about.
I'm talking about making forward progress
and then regressing, and then being like
I feel like I'm in a better
place in some respects,
so not like Paula Abdul.
Like a song that I can't come up with
right now in which I...
I'm glad you asked the question
because I talked to my therapist
right when I got back from the trip.
What we talked about was how you take
this moment that you had
and then entering back
into normal life.
Normal life wants to undo everything.
It wants to drag you
back into its normalcy,
and your routines, and your habits,
and the way that you see
the world by default.
That has been a struggle
because it's been weeks now
since I got back.
I expected that.
I didn't go in thinking
that I was gonna come back a
completely different person.
I was like, this is
about the journey, man.
It's about incremental change
in the right direction.
That's all I can hope for.
The thing that I did...
I mean, it wasn't a solo trip,
but the trip with
Christie was very special
when we went to Utah.
I came back, and I was actually talking
to my therapist about it.
Then one of the things that he said was,
he suggested that I make up a photo album.
A scrapbook.
Well, all of my photos
are in Google photos, so.
Did he use the term scrapbook?
No, I just put them into...
You can order a hard or soft bag.
Apple did it first.
Always go hard.
Now Google does it, and I went hard.
I surprised Christie with it
just so we could have something physical
where it's like memorialize the occasion,
and I put some funny captions in there
like on that one campsite.
It was like, you're selling hotdogs?
That kind of thing.
Yeah, that brings back the
right kind of memories.
I don't think we would
have forgotten that.
A side note, Google photos books suck ass.
Compared to Apple?
Compared to Apple.
Next time I would download...
They altered all of my photos.
They'd tried to enhance them.
Google did?
Yeah, Google's trying
to saturate my photos.
My photos are the way I want my photos.
Don't apply some general
saturation to everything
that you're printing to where it's like-
If anything you need to desaturate.
Just leave it.
I want it.
I took the picture.
If I wanted to edit it,
I would have done that.
I'm not a dummy.
I'm pretty sure that next time
I'm just gonna download
them all from Google
and I'm gonna upload them
to Apple just to do that.
Even though I don't keep my stuff...
I have a Mac.
I use Google photos.
Now you run into a problem here.
I'll tell you this one story
from going to Joshua Tree.
We got an Airbnb.
It was this place.
It was a 30 minute drive from
the entrance to Joshua Tree
north of a place called Pioneertown,
which they film some stuff there.
They have a makeshift, western town,
and I think Ice Cube
shot a music video there.
How does that add up.
I don't know.
Anyway, so we're out there and the booklet
for the Airbnb there
is tell you what to do
and what not to do.
If you bring a dog, you
better put them on a sheet
on the couch and that stuff.
They said, out of respect
for our neighbors...
This house was in the middle
of this desert valley.
We arrived at night,
and I couldn't tell if there
were any other houses around
for reasons I'll get into,
but they weren't that close.
It's like the neighbors weren't that close
the next morning I could tell.
The reason why is because of
what they said in the booklet,
out of respect for the neighbors,
only use outside lighting
when absolutely necessary
and then turn off your
lights so that there...
It decreases light pollution
to help us stargaze.
People are out here in the
desert to see the stars.
I'm real tuned into that
ever since the last trip.
It was a big selling point.
They had a hot tub out there
in the middle of the backyard just like-
Nice.
Then you get in the hot
tub, and you just lean back,
and you look at this expansive sky
and see what I schooled
Lily on was the Milky Way.
That first night I mean, they
had flashlights so that...
Because you can't turn the lights off
once you get in the hot tub.
You gotta turn them off from the house
and then walk out and try not
to trip on the Joshua Tree
and the cacti and the rocks and stuff.
You're using your flashlight.
You getting out there.
We turn off the lights in the hot tub too,
so it's very black.
We're looking up at the stars,
but we're having a good old time.
All of a sudden, Lando goes, oh.
You're like what?
He was like, I just tasted something.
It tasted like sausage.
I said, and we all are what
like, we're like, what?
Lando is the type that I...
Lando is a very reactionary kid.
Wouldn't you say?
Yes.
He's particular about things.
He's a bit queer, kinda
like me meaning that he's...
Well, I don't wanna have to
re-explain what that means,
but it just means particular.
We didn't wanna say, dude,
there is no sausage floating
in this pool.
Apparently, he had put his mouth down
at the surface level of the water
and he got something in
his mouth and he said-
I thought he had burped and
was tasting dinner again.
No, no.
We had not had sausage that
night, or the day before.
He had put his mouth down at the water
and gotten something in his mouth
that he said tasted like sausage.
We didn't wanna alarm him.
From before I had turned the light off,
I was the first one
out there with Lincoln,
and Lincoln was like, you
need to get these bugs out
of the hot tub.
I didn't wanna tell him that...
I was pretty sure because
I didn't get the bugs out.
There was only two of them.
Now there's only one of them
I didn't wanna tell him.
Dude, I think you ate a bug or worse.
I mean, so as far as I
know, as far as he knows,
he ate a sausage because
the way that he said it,
he said, I just got something in my mouth.
It tastes like sausage.
I could tell by the way he said it.
It was probably a moth.
That he did eat it.
It was probably a moth, I could imagine.
He chewed it up, tasted it,
experienced the sensation of sausage-
Why would he chew it?
Then I think, I don't know.
I think he just got it in his mouth.
I think it came in with a
gulp of water or something.
Well, I think he swallowed it.
He was like, he said it
in a way that was like,
I just got something in my
mouth that tasted like sausage.
Is this sausage water?
Is there like a sausage
water in this hot tub?
I'm telling you more than I'm telling him,
but he ate something that
I'm afraid is not sausage.
You haven't talked to him about it?
Even days later?
We would make fun of...
It's like, man, this tastes like sausage
for a lot of things, for
the rest of the weekend.
He didn't bit it again.
Mission accomplished.
He never freaked out, but I do
not know exactly what he ate.
It was definitely a bug because I can...
Having eaten lots of bugs-
A soggy sausage-like bugs.
I can imagine, especially an uncooked bug.
At least, I mean, I guess it's parboiled
because it's in the-
A lot of chemicals in there.
It's in the hot tub, but I could tell,
It's got a little spice to it
and you can't quite reconcile,
so you just go with sausage.
I get it.
Well, I'll tell him the
next time I see him.
Oh my God.
I was just glad he didn't freak out.
Yeah, because if you had to told him
that he just ate a bug, it
may have ruined your night.
Ruin the evening.
It wouldn't have been
about the stars anymore.
Sometimes the truth is not worth.
Yeah, I only tell the truth
when it's convenient for me.
Now, let's answer some of these questions,
but first let's just let you know
about something that we are
very, very excited about.
We don't have a copy of it here.
As of the recording,
it's still being printed,
but that's-
We know what it looks like though.
This is a high quality product.
It's a coloring book for
adults and adult children.
If you've been paying
attention to just the evolution
of culture over the past decade or so-
Everybody colors.
Everybody's coloring now.
You don't have to be a child anymore.
We have basically taken
the world of mythicality
and some of your favorite things
that you have experienced
through the world of mythicality,
and translated them into these
incredibly intricate illustrations
that then you can colorize.
Just what Google did to Link's photos.
You can saturate these.
That's actually the point.
To your own liking, you're
in complete control.
A lot of hidden gems in there.
A lot of pages.
Went through a lot of
that, had a lot of notes.
You know me.
I like to give a lot of
notes on illustrations
that involve us and our characters
and our mythical crew and
our past and our future.
Mythical.com.
Grab yourself the one,
the only official mythical coloring book.
Okay, let's start-
What you wanna do?
With a question from Kanes Cab Driver,
BudIceYall.
What's the proper amount
of time to honk at somebody
when the light turns
green and they don't go?
I give them a five second courtesy,
but my wife gives them three seconds.
Oh, they're both timey.
Now, I can't say that I
have an immediate answer.
I'm gonna have to arrive at something
because they've talked about
it and are in a constant count.
I just can't live that way.
I go on feel, I go on feel.
You go on feel.
I think it's because I mean,
if you're gonna do a count,
then you're obligating yourself
to do a count every time.
Then most of the time you're
wasting all this energy
counting on someone who's gonna go
before you get to three seconds.
Certainly before, I mean,
if it's two seconds,
you're not gonna honk.
That's two seconds of
counting in order to...
I just don't like the spirit of counting
believing that someone's not gonna go.
That's believing the worst in somebody.
I like to believe the best in people.
Philosophically I don't like this,
and I also don't like it practically
because I'm sitting there counting
when I should be focused on driving.
In any given 10 scenarios
where this happen 10 times,
and let's just say the person doesn't go,
and it's in the first three
or five seconds, whatever.
How many times are you going to...
Let's say somebody goes five seconds.
Just based on your experience-
10 times.
How many times will you
beep in that scenario?
I'm saying beep, honk,
whatever your term is.
First of all, I do think,
I think three's too short.
I think five is courteous.
I'm actually adding a check into the cab.
If I can see that they're
looking down at something-
That's the only -
Probably their phone-
That's the only thing I go on.
Then it's so it's five
seconds... Waiting long enough
at a green light to make
me to look in the cab
and determined that they're
not looking at the light...
However long that takes
that's when I'm honking.
When I feel like they need
me to honk is when I honk.
You know what I'm saying?
At that point, it's not that
I'm giving you a courtesy
by waiting to honk.
I'm giving you a courtesy by honking
because I'm saying, hey
bro, the light turned green.
I don't hate you.
How's your new car?
It's just we're all in this together.
For the friendly tap honk
when you're just like,
how's your new car do with that?
Have you done the friendly tap honk?
I typically only do the...
I can't remember the last time
I did the lay on the horn thing.
I did one coming back from Joshua Tree.
Really?
There was some merging situation,
and I knew from my GPS that
we're about to hit some traffic.
Somebody just,
I'm slowing down and then all of a sudden
they're barreling in there,
getting in between me
and the guy in front of me,
even though there's a line
of like five miles of
bumper to bumper traffic.
It made that much of a
difference to get in front of me
instead of behind me.
I laid on the...
It was this long.
That long.
I see, that's pretty offensive.
I'm a pretty reluctant honker
because I feel like the
vast majority of honks
that people here are not intended for them
and freak them out because
that's what happens
to me all the time.
It happened to you.
It's like, who, are you honking at me?
Then I like, oh, they
weren't honking at me.
Now, I'm not paying attention to driving.
I'm thinking about who honked at me.
I wonder how many accidents are a result
of an errant honk.
I don't hardly, I never do
the lay it on the horn unless...
I mean, I'm not saying I've never done it,
but I have to be like this
person just did something
that endangered my life
or someone else's life.
At that point I'm gonna honk.
I think I felt that.
Cutting in front of me is
like you may piss me off,
but I try not to get too
worked up about that.
The other reason I'm
a little bit reluctant
to honk with a new car is that
it has this feature where you-
That's the gas too.
You can hook up an external
hard drive to the car.
What?
It will capture your dashcam footage.
Every time you honk,
it records the last 10 minutes
are automatically put onto the hard drive.
Every time you honk.
The idea is, if you were
about to be in an accident,
and you honked the horn,
well, or if you just...
Something just happened.
You can honk the horn.
You're not thinking straight.
You don't have to go into
the menu and hit record.
You just honked the horn,
and that takes the last
10 minutes of action
that the dashcam has captured
and puts it onto the hard drive.
Because why not?
I mean, who knows somebody
cut in front of you,
you're in an accident,
insurance stuff, whatever.
Because I'm adding footage
to a hard drive when I honk-
You don't like that.
It's like this extra thing to consider.
Do I wanna record this?
Well, the car doesn't get heavier.
No, I know.
I mean, it's like a-
Oh, my God, the car's going slower.
It's like a 500 gig hard drive.
It's not that big of a deal,
but it feels like I'm making...
It's like the fact that-
It seems like something I would think.
I'm surprised that you're thinking.
You won't run the air conditioning on high
because you think it's gonna
break the air conditioning.
You told me that one time.
Don't put it on high now.
It's not made to go on high.
The max AC button-
You don't like max AC, max AC?
Yeah.
I'll do max AC all day long.
The beeping of the horn
to record the things-
You've created a file.
I don't wanna create a file
unless it's absolutely necessary.
Where it's like when you
hand your phone to somebody
to take a picture.
Again, while we're doing the park thing.
One family member is taking the picture,
and I'm like, hey, just
frame it up, decide,
and then take one or two.
One or two.
Don't take five or 10 because
when they hand it back,
what's the first thing I do?
I look at what you got I
delete the four to nine
that I don't like.
That's for the live photo
feature on iPhone's for though.
I've got that setting on my default.
If somebody blinked, I can
just... It's still one file.
Go back to where they didn't blink.
Then if you hand your phone to somebody,
they don't know that that's on,
and then they're taking more photos.
Then you got...
That bothers me.
You don't like burst mode, I assume.
Oh, God. I hate burst mode.
We're agreeing.
We don't think that there's a time limit.
We think you should go on
feel and take into account
the environment on this, but
three seconds is too short.
Your wife is jumping the gun.
I feel confident in that.
Your car also has a dog mode.
Yeah.
Tesla has a dog mode.
Have you tried dog mode,
put Barbara in the car?
What does that do, by the way?
When you put the car into dog mode,
you can leave your dog
in the car and keep it-
It will tell her where to go.
You sit it to the car.
Go to Ralph's, give me some half and half.
This is a parked car, not a moving car.
You leave your dog in a parked car.
It does two things.
The first thing it does is it
keeps the ambient temperature
in the cabin something
that won't kill your dog.
The second thing it does
is when somebody comes up to your car,
it senses that somebody is at your car,
and it puts a message on the giant display
in the middle that says, "I'm okay.
My owner will be right back."
In other words, don't call the pet cops.
I'm fine.
I bet you people who care enough to call
won't believe that sign.
You can hear that the car is
on when the dog's in there.
I mean, I haven't done it.
First of all, your car runs all the time.
Well, only if you put it in that mode.
If I go out into the parking
lot, your car is running.
Only if it's in...
It has a special feature where
if the cabin gets too hot,
it'll cool it down.
That's cool.
It was so hot one day in
the middle of the summer
that it burned like 60
miles off of the battery
just to keep it from being like 180°-
You deactivated that.
Yeah.
You haven't done dog mode,
and there's a sign that
comes up and says, don't...
Just stay out of my business.
My dog is fine.
This is a Tesla.
Yeah, my owner is coming back.
I haven't used it.
We've never-
Because dog lovers-
We don't really leave-
Dog lovers will, they'll
get in that business.
I guess rightfully so because people-
We don't leave Barbara in the car.
We take Barbara in the car
if we're going someplace
that Barbara is supposed
to get out with us.
We don't just like,
she's not an accessory that
we just throw in the car
and then go into a grocery
store or something like that.
We really haven't had
an occasion to use it.
Also the people who come up to your car
they're being recorded.
This is a cool feature.
I'm sure this is available on other cars,
but the reason that there's a hard drive
that you can attach to the car
is that you put it in century mode.
I'm not trying to do an ad
for Tesla at this point,
but it kind of is turning into that.
You put it in a century mode,
and what that does is it...
Anybody who comes up to your car,
opens their door into your door,
it records them and then
puts that on the hard drive.
If you're like who busted
this dent in my car?
This guy in this car
with this license plate.
See I'm a fan of having
cameras everywhere.
Big Brother.
That was my favorite thing about London.
I mean, when we got in
traffic, and all of a sudden,
Christie, I was like Christie,
what are you looking at on your phone?
She was like, well, I felt like
I left the oven on at home.
I'm looking back at our camera-
To see if it's burning.
Because I got a camera in our kitchen-
You probably can't tell-
I don't know why.
It is a heat sensing camera
because it's not gonna be
able to tell if the oven's on.
No, she said, okay, I'm going back here.
Here I am turning the oven-
She's gonna go back
and look it up herself.
Get this stuff out of the oven,
and then she could actually zoom in.
The way the camera is set up,
it she could zoom in enough on the oven
to see that it turned off.
HD.
It's got an oven cam.
I'm very interested in this
question from Omni_draws.
If you both didn't know each other
and saw each other for
the first time in life
then would you talk with each other
or even enjoy each other?
You both aren't YouTubers.
Just two regular guys.
We're just two regular guys.
We're not YouTubers.
Well, first of all, as Kiko pointed out
this is Buddy System season two.
This is the premise for the season.
If you haven't watched
Buddy System, check it out.
There's a song in every episode.
You can watch it for free now.
There's us acting.
You can watch it all for free.
It's all free on YouTube.
It's all free.
Buddy System season two has
nothing to do with season one.
If you don't like season
one, season two is better.
You don't need to have watched season one,
or to have liked season
one to like season two.
Correct.
Man, so we meet for the first time.
Here's how I evaluate this.
On paper, there's a lot
that would be working
in our favor to be friends.
Assuming both from the
south, similar music taste.
Things that are just true about us
that they may be true about us
because we grew up together.
Just assuming in the same way
that on that episode of GMM
where we pictured the same
color when we smelled.
We have a lot in common in that way,
but there's a balancing factor.
That is me and you both have a tendency
to come into a social scene
and I'm not talking about
like an industry party.
We did a whole episode on that
about how you are the
I'm gonna go up to people
and talk to them.
I'm kind of like, you go do that.
In a friend of friends
type party situation,
I feel like I bring a little
bit too much of a critical eye
into those situations, where I'm not...
I don't go into those situations thinking
everyone here is a potential friend.
Do you know what I'm saying?
I feel based on the conversations
that we've had after we've
gone to places together
that you approach things in a similar way.
I think I do.
I think there's a couple of factors here.
It's hard to remove the fact
that we have such a strong friendship
that whenever we enter those situations
and evaluate why we're
acting the way we're acting,
one factor is we don't
have a strong felt need
to make friends with people.
I mean, we're busy and we have each other.
I mean, and we each have
other friends we share.
We share a bunch of friends,
and then there's some that's like,
okay, maybe you have more of
a connection to this person
than me or vice versa.
There's not really a felt need beyond that
to keep adding people
because the second thing is
neither one of us, at this phase
of our life are extroverts.
We're both more introverted.
I actually think we feel...
We may feel more introverted
than we actually are
because of the previous reason.
I do get energized by
talking to the people
that I enjoy being around
and the friends that I'm closest with.
I miss your game night since COVID
because that was a place where
our larger circle of friends
we would hang out.
I'm missing that.
If you again, you take COVID
out as out of the situation too,
I'm just not looking to
make new friends at all.
Let's remove that.
If you remove that, if
you remove all of that,
I think, we might sense
what might be like,
oh, I can be friends with this guy
that we could pick up on some
of the things you're talking about.
I got a similar what we...
I think we have a similar vibe.
If we still have our looks
about us and our wits about us-
I don't think it's a friend making vibe.
That's my premise.
I think it might backfire.
I think it might be the
type of thing that's like,
okay, we're operating in a similar circle.
Very self-aware.
It's like this is...
What's the saying, not too
many cooks in the kitchen,
but like that.
This town isn't big
enough for the both of us.
I think it's what we might sense.
It's just like, I'm not
gonna talk to that guy.
You know what,
I feel like my mentality on
that has changed a little bit.
Think about this with
taking North Carolina
and then taking Los Angeles
and contrasting the two.
Los Angeles is filled with people
who think they're the shit.
In a lot of ways may have been the shit
at some point in their life
where they lived somewhere else
and then they moved to Los Angeles.
You've got all these ambitious people
who consider themselves.
They have a disposition to be famous,
which already makes you
a certain kind of person.
Now, again, whether we like it or not,
we both have a disposition
to want to be well known.
It's one of the reasons
that we do what we do,
and that's a certain kind of person.
Is that when I'm supposed
to say speak for yourself.
I think that it's almost,
if we met in North Carolina,
and I don't think we bring that
kind of energy into a room.
You don't bring that kind of energy.
I don't bring that kind of energy.
In fact, I don't want people to know
what it is I do or my...
I prefer entering into a conversation
with people not knowing the deal.
Knowing I have a YouTube thing,
you don't have to explain it or whatever.
I don't bring that kind of energy,
but I have changed the
way I feel about that.
I look beyond that
because sometimes you would go to a party
and there's somebody
who's a huge personality
and they're like, all of a sudden
there's a crowd around them.
I try not to get intimidated
or turned off by that
because I feel like it
can happen really easily
in Los Angeles.
You wouldn't do that.
You wouldn't be like that.
I don't think I would be like that.
I don't necessarily think-
Yeah, I think we would both be quieter.
I think it would be the type of thing
where it's like that
guy looks interesting,
and he's not being loud.
I think I would strike up a conversation
with this tall guy who
needs to be groomed.
But you might not know,
because I get this a lot.
People who are friends
with my wife tell...
My wife is like, she can make
friends with a can of beans.
She she's bubbly and she is super honest
and vulnerable with people
right when she meets them.
Us being in a relationship,
we have a way of making
friends with people
because people are gonna really
gravitate towards my wife
and she's gonna seem open.
She's great at talking to people.
Are you saying that you get
people's first impression
of you through her relaying it?
No, what I'm saying is
that in contrast to her,
a lot of times people who
are her friends will say,
yeah, I thought that Rhett didn't like me.
That's what I'm saying.
For the first year that you were friends.
Yeah, maybe you didn't.
Again, I'm not trying to step into this,
but I feel like I don't
consider either of us
a particularly warm
person upon first meeting
in a way that our wives, I think,
are both more warm in a way.
Sometimes it can be
interpreted the wrong way,
and you might be like,
this guy does like me.
Because in that type of setting,
again, I go back to the motivation.
I'm just not motivated to do the work
because it's work to
connect with somebody,
and it's a big risk.
I just think it's a lot of
work to get to know somebody.
Then you may not connect and
then you're just starting over.
It's like every time you get
to a light that turns green,
you start counting.
It's like again, I know
that's a lot of work to count.
I believe in the end, the thing that...
When we get to know new people,
I feel like the thing that
for better, for worse,
the thing that I'm looking for is...
I'm not looking for it,
but I'm looking to not
be annoyed by the person.
All of a sudden it's like,
now, there's a personality
thing about them
or the way that they're
presenting themselves
that I can see that getting old quick.
I think this is probably...
This isn't a super conscious process,
but I think that's what's happening
as you get to know people.
I think that as different
as we are, and again,
this is probably because
we've known each other forever
and we've molded each
other in a certain way.
Assuming that we would essentially
be the same person apart,
I think that in a normal conversation
we would not annoy each other.
No.
I actually think that that-
I think our first, the end
of our first conversation
would not be that far from
any conversation that we would have.
Neither of us are
instigators when it comes to,
hey, do you wanna go
play gold or anything?
What guys ask each other...
Basically when guys wanna be friends,
and they wanna be friends with each other
and not friends as
couples, a lot of times-
What are you gonna do?
Your significant other, in my case Jesse,
will be the one who
coordinates the next time
that the couples get together.
It's like, well, do you like
him, and do you like her?
If it's just two guys, and then...
What would step two be like?
Let's get together and play pool.
Neither one of us have
that in our bag of tricks.
Again, we're super busy.
I think a lot of times we'll be like,
hey, let's get together
and talk about this idea.
We'll do it.
It's like a project based thing,
but we just don't hang that much.
What you said at the
beginning was something
about we liked the same type of music.
What would be the opening conversation?
First of all, I do think
that I would probably...
I'd be like, hey, I
got I'm in a good mood,
I'm at this place, I'm
gonna talk to somebody,
but who am I gonna talk to?
It maximizes my chances in conversation
to connect with somebody.
I will look for somebody who
looks a little interesting,
and it's like, okay, this...
That is the thing that
I've enjoyed about LA
is you can go to some get together
and there's all these people
that you can judge them
on the surface and think
that that person looks weird
or interesting or-
Well, everybody has taken more
than the average amount of
time to present themselves
in a certain way.
People have honed people
have honed their way
that they present themselves.
Again, nothing against North Carolina.
It might make people, it might
mean people are more sane.
I mean, especially where we
come from, you go to a party.
It's like all the dudes
are gonna be dressed
in a similar like a...
They're gonna be on the
same part of the spectrum.
Sexual spectrum.
I'm not talking about that.
I'm talking about the clothing spectrum.
It's like, all these
guys went to the same-
Gap.
Section of the mall.
All these guys go to
the same kind of barber.
You know what I'm saying?
Because it's not a town of-
People are showing off.
I'm gonna be benevolent here,
expressing themselves visually, anyway.
They're just not as much-
I think what would happen is,
I would initiate a conversation.
I'd be like, I just don't
know what I would say.
You mentioned music.
If music was playing and
I probably say something
about the music-
I hate rock, what about you?
U2 too, I'm not really into-
Yeah, I respect him.
I would like a little more soul.
You've been to Joshua Tree?
You know Joshua Trees only
grow at certain elevations.
Sometimes people try to find
the one from that U2 album.
Then it wouldn't be like,
"Hey, let's get together
and listen to music."
You gotta be a close friend to say that.
This is the most
interesting question for me.
Then you end up talking about-
What's the next step in our relationship
in this world that we're in?
Because then it's like, well,
here's what we would do.
The easiest things to
talk about, first of all,
I tell you what do you do for a living?
We've already ruled that out.
We can't talk about that.
We might talk about music.
You end up talking about
shows you're watching.
I think we'd have a great conversation-
About shows.
Then we would never talk again.
I'm beginning to form a
picture of what this...
It would be like, I
remember that Link guy,
I met in that party, really
interesting conversation.
I wonder what he's up
to, but I'm not gonna...
I didn't get his number.
I'm not gonna call him. What
would I do if I called him?
He didn't wanna go play golf with me.
I'm not gonna sit down
and just have coffee.
You know what I'm saying?
I really think, I don't...
I guess what it is.
I don't know what it's like to be-
Sitting down and having
coffee could work, but that...
I mean, that is a vulnerable move.
I mean, that's asking a guy out on a date.
It's like, hey, you
wanna meet up for coffee?
This is a question hashtag Ear Biscuits
for everybody listening because
as guys who've been married
to the same women, for two decades,
who grew up together, who have
a pretty solid friend group,
There hasn't been, outside
of work-related stuff,
there just hasn't been many
that's like what's the next step
in a platonic relationship with somebody.
I feel like I'm asking
a fundamental question
because I don't have to worry about it.
I know that a lot of people...
We feel there's so many
questions over the years.
You talk about friendship,
a lot of people ask that question to us.
Do you have any advice for making friends?
It's like, I think what we're
saying is, it's never easy.
You're in a social situation,
and then you just find
somebody that you size up
that you feel is like you.
Unless you've really made
a decision to find someone
who you just by judging them externally
that they're not like
you that's a sad thing.
Well, I think, I would say you're looking
for a point of connection.
Point of connect.
When you say I like you.
There's some kind of point of connection.
It doesn't necessarily mean
this person looks like you
or is from your background.
If they're making the same face
they're judging this get
together as much as I am.
I'm gonna go stand beside
them and judge it too.
I don't know what we
learned about each other
and exploring that question, but it was-
I think you said we'd be
ships passing in the night.
We'd have a great conversation,
but it would take something that I can't-
It would take our wives
exchanging numbers.
To become friends.
Yeah.
Sadly, so we don't have
to worry about that
because we are friends.
You know what, if I needed...
If I had a felt need
for a friend, I would...
I'd be like, I'd probably
say something awkward like,
hey, man, I really like you.
Let's hang out.
Listen, I think I would be-
I don't have any close friends here.
I think I would be
ready to admit that too.
If you have close friends,
maybe you can introduce me to them.
Maybe I like them better than I like you.
Can I use you as a way
to meet your friends?
I'm just joking.
Can we get coffee?
That's exactly what I would say.
It would be a self-deprecating,
vulnerable exchange, tearless.
If I wanted friends,
I wouldn't let that situation happen.
I'd be like, hey, you know because I mean,
I guess there have been times in my life
when I've met somebody
that I connected with
and I was like, let me get your number.
I don't know if I've-
You're thinking of an instance?
Because I was thinking-
I'd say I've done that like
three to five times in my life.
I was thinking of our mutual
friends from game night,
and it's like, somebody like Ward.
That's somebody that we knew,
we met through YouTube years ago
and then when we moved
out here, we reconnected.
Then you think about Daniel.
It's like, okay, he was our
director on Commercial Kings.
We were introduced through
work, and then we just...
We don't talk all the
time, but we keep in touch.
Meaning that the scenario
that we're talking about
where you just meet at a party isn't how
we really made any of our friends.
It's like it was a circumstance
in which we were...
It was work-related, and
then we just had a connection
where like this is deeper
than just a work relationship.
This is a friend.
Then you just leaned into that.
It's still hard.
Especially now.
Well, yes, especially now,
but when you institutionalized
the game night thing
that helped because every month there was-
It shall happen again.
Even if you miss a couple,
you know you can get back in there.
There's a few other friends,
but it's not like there's not that many.
You can only have so many friends.
Especially now when...
We'd done a couple of Zoom
double date type things
with a few of those friends.
Then we'd done a couple
of triple dates with us
and McHugh or whatever.
That was happening with more regularity
at the beginning of COVID.
Now, people are just
like, we're just gonna...
It's funny, I know that it-
It fizzled out.
It depends on what part
of the country you're in
and where you're at.
Again, to continue the contrast
with LA, North Carolina.
I know back in North Carolina,
things are very different from at least,
in terms of the way that my
family is communicating to me
about the way that their
lives are different
but not that different.
Whereas here in California
and Los Angeles,
especially things are
still pretty much the same
as they were five months ago.
We're not seeing...
If we're gonna see
somebody that it'd be like,
hey, let's all come over
and hang out outside,
but we haven't even done much of that.
Because then it's like there's
gonna be masks involved
and it's kind of annoying.
You're in this place where
you're just not that motivated
to make things happen.
Well, the thing, I think...
What I'm thinking right now is for someone
who had just moved, and this
is probably the situation
for lots of people.
If you just moved to a new place-
It's horrible.
In the midst of this,
and you are the kind of person
who is taking it seriously,
and trying to maintain social distancing
and masks and stuff like that.
Your ability to make new friends
is really impeded right now.
Something else we haven't
had to worry about.
You know what?
It'll be over at some point.
That's all I can say.
I can also ask another question.
Autumn.
Hit this one right quick
because I want to address this.
We don't want to spend too much time on.
Skyler Bradford has tweeted at
mythical, but this is for me.
As a Utah resident,
I can't get over how Link was saying Zion
in your latest podcast.
It cracked me up.
It's Zie-un to the locals.
That's been on my mind for a few days.
Zie-un. Zie-un. Zie-un.
Zie-un. Zie-un.
Zion.
We like to hit the second syllable, man.
It is a little bit of a southern, Zion.
It's not always a second syllable
because we would say, unique not unique.
That's true.
Unique.
We pick a syllable and we go hard.
Yeah, on the wrong one sometimes.
The reason why I say Zion is because
in the Lauren Hill song, she says Zion.
Yeah, Mount Zion.
Zion.
Zie-un is just...
That's a local thing, but
Zion means a whole lot more.
Not just for Mormons.
Zion's not just for Mormons anymore.
A lot of time.
Well, you're saying that
because it's in Utah.
Well, yeah, the Mormons named it Zion.
Right, but Zion is in the Bible as well.
Yeah, I know, I was just saying-
Which means is probably in
the book of Mormon as well.
I don't know.
I don't know the full origin story.
I know there's a lot
of stuff from the Bible
in the book of Mormon though.
The Mormons named everything in the park.
Really?
Yeah, I think the
indigenous peoples probably
they also had names for everything.
Matter of fact, I know they did.
Let's not get into that.
Zion.
I'll try man.
Skyler, I will try.
For you, I will try.
Zie-un.
Not Zion.
You're going to Zion?
Zie-un.
You're going to Zie-un?
Yeah, I'm on my way, am a local.
Science question that intrigued me.
This is from Autumn, 7autumn5 on Twitter.
Why does warm water feel so
much better than warm air?
A really hot shower is awesome,
but if I were in a 100˚
room I'd be uncomfortable.
It's a great question.
I looked up just to make sure
that the way I was thinking about this,
and I didn't have it...
I didn't completely
understand what was going on.
I think a good place
to start is let's start
with a lower temperature.
If you're outside and it's 70...
Well, 70˚ is the approximate temperature
at which a human feels
comfortable in the air.
If the air is 70˚ it's like
most people feel pretty comfortable.
That is based on the idea that your body
is doing all these different
metabolic processes
that is generating heat
and you're dissipating the heat
through a number of processes
like the blood flowing close
to the surface of your skin
so you give off a little bit of heat.
You're breathing and there's hot air
that's coming out of you,
and/or your sweating,
you're perspiring as you're
cooling yourself down.
Don't forget the gold standard farting.
Farting releases a lot of-
Heat, heat.
Methane as they say
across the pond and heat.
It turns out that the reason
you feel comfortable at 70˚-
It's like a blowtorch down there.
Is because all these
things that are happening
in your body is in a good state
of equilibrium at about 70˚.
It's not equally.
It's actually cooling.
There is a gradient not equilibrium.
Well, when I say equilibrium I mean,
I'm talking about the process
of you dissipating heat
is at a place where your body
is doing it most efficiently,
and you're not having to do
it too little or too much.
You're not having to reserve the heat,
and you're also not having
to cool yourself down
and make yourself uncomfortable.
The body is doing this in
a most efficient manner.
I think what you're saying
is, the rate of cooling-
Is what makes you feel good.
Makes you feel good.
Because if it gets cooler,
if it gets down to 65,
it starts to suck heat out of
your body to a point where-
Now, you've got to put clothes on.
Now I've got to do
something to alter this.
I'm getting signals that I'm uncomfortable
because this could lead to...
If this continues forever-
I could die.
If it gets too hot, it's like,
well, we really gotta sweat.
We gotta breathe harder.
That makes you feel uncomfortable,
but you know that if you're
in ocean water or water,
at 70˚ you're, that's cold.
What exactly is happening?
It all comes down to the heat transfer.
That's right, why?
Everything we said should
apply to 70˚ water.
No, it turns out that water
feels perfect at 93.5˚.
That is the-
Seriously?
That is a temperature that
most sensory deprivation tanks are set at.
They set at that temperature
because your skin doesn't
sense the presence of water
because it's...
For whatever reason, you are basically
in that same state of equilibrium at 93
and a half degrees in water.
Of course, if it was 93˚,
93.5˚ outside, it would be hot.
What's happening is
the heat transfer coefficient of water
is 50 times greater than that of air.
Basically what's happening
is you've got this body
that's operating at 98.6˚
on average and generating this heat,
and it's releasing this heat.
As soon as you get into 70˚
of water, it's sucking it out.
It's sucking put your heat 50 times.
50 times as efficiently.
That's why you immediately feel cold,
and if you stayed in that 70˚ water
for any good length of
time, you'd get hypothermia.
Let's go up to the question
that was asked which is 100˚.
Here's the thing.
If you get into a 100˚ hot
tub, if it's a 100˚ outside,
it ain't gonna feel good.
You're gonna get in there
and you're gonna be immediately hot.
Usually what happens is you
get into a 100˚ hot tub,
and it's less than that outside.
What do you do?
Do you get into a hot tub
and go under and stay under?
You get in and you're
like, it's getting hot.
I gotta get my arms out.
I gotta get my head out of the water.
Your arms and your head
are dissipating heat
into the ambient air which is what 70˚
or whatever it happens to be outside.
It's really nice when
it's like 45˚ outside
and you just skied all day
and you get into a hot tub
and it's snowing or something like that.
That's great.
Remember when we did that?
Because that's because
your body is dissipating
all that heat.
I do.
You're in that state of equilibrium,
but you still get the
benefit of this hot, soothing
water around your skin.
The reason why warm water-
Warm water.
Feels so much better than warm air
is because of the coefficient.
Because of the-
50 times seems like a lot.
Yeah, I mean, think about it.
It's also like the heat
transfer coefficient
of metal is a lot higher than air.
That's why if you like, if it's 70˚
and you wrap yourself in
70˚ metal, you would also...
It would feel cold to you
because it's pulling that
body heat out as well.
I don't know how that compares to water.
The difference between water and air
is the heat coefficient.
Once you get up to 100˚,
you're actually getting
to a place that the water
and the air are technically higher
than your core body
temperature at that point.
You're trying to dissipate
that heat all the time,
but now you're dissipating
it into an environment
that is hotter than your
own body temperature.
It really starts working hard.
When you're in a hot tub,
even if you feel good,
you're actually sweating quite a bit.
There's a lot of sweat that's happening.
There's a lot of blood
flow that's happening
in the parts of your body that
are near the surface as well.
That's why it makes it good for you.
I guess.
I would have thought because
water is more dense than air
that it would serve as
more of an installation
that it wouldn't...
It's like wearing a coat.
What's the coefficient of a coat?
Well, I don't think that
the insulation factor
and the heat transfer is
necessarily the same thing
because if you were to put...
If you were to fill a wall, if
there was a wall around you,
in your house, right now
you fill it with insulation
because that keeps the
heat from going through it.
Does that mean that the
heat transfer coefficient
of water is higher than air,
if you put water in
the walls of your house
assuming that was possible?
That it would do a worse job
of keeping you warm or cold.
Yes, I think it will because-
It seems to be.
Because a vacuum is the best insulator.
That's why if you...
They'll put a vacuum sealed thermos
or if you have double pane windows,
then they can put...
Well they put in there,
I don't think they'll create a vacuum.
That's why you can get in-
Maybe.
A sauna and get it up to 200˚ or whatever.
You can get a sauna up to 220˚
which is above a boiling
water temperature-
You cannot get in a hot tub
that's over 104 by law, I think.
Right, if you get into 150˚ tub of water,
you're gonna burn your skin.
If you get into 150˚ sauna,
you're gonna be like
this isn't hot enough.
I want it to be hotter.
That's the proof right there.
I know you're not full of bull crap.
You wanna wreck, baby wreck,
baby one, two, three, four.
I've got a music wreck for you.
Now, I've already given
you this music wreck.
I'm giving this to everybody else.
Have you gone back and
listened to this because-
I don't remember which one it is.
All right, fine.
I'll give it to you again.
Good Ol' Willie Nelson
has a son, Lukas Nelson.
Lukas with a K, and he has a band
called Lukas Nelson & Promise of the Real.
It's a great band name.
I think they're a jam band situation.
Promise of the Real definitely is the name
of what should be a jam band.
I'm talking about a Grateful Dead.
Sounds a little Grateful Dead.
Promise of the Real because it's got...
When you talk about what's real,
it seems like something that would-
In the promise of it.
Yeah, that you'd wanna really
get in a jam band situation.
By the way, you talk about
famous country music singer sons.
We connected with Merle's youngest son.
We got a record yesterday sent to us,
and it was a Shooter Jennings record,
and I was so excited to report to you
what Jenna reported to me.
It was like, there's two
Shooter Jennings records here.
The only thing it came
with was a post-it note.
In the post-it note it said,
"Thanks for occupying us
and giving us a lot of laughs
on the road dash Shooter."
Freaking Waylon Jennings
son, Shooter Jennings.
He's an artist, producer, musician,
mainstay in his own right.
Freaking wrote us a note
said that he watches us
and sends us his album.
Freaking cool.
Now we gotta connect with Lukas.
We gotta connect with Lukas Nelson,
and you gotta connect with...
Lukas may not be happy
that I'm recommending
one of the earliest
songs that they put out.
This is from 2014.
I'm just obsessed with this song.
It's called Find Yourself.
It's a good one.
It's off of the album called Sampler.
It's basically is three songs on it,
but it's presented as a single from 2014
with a couple of other songs.
The phrase, I said it on the show,
"You're a sweet peach, know your worth."
That's basically the premise of that song.
He's like, I'll let you listen to it.
The thing that hooked me was
just the groove of this song.
He's got a really good groove,
and then you got this...
It's like, well, this sounds
like freaking Willie Nelson singing,
but a little bit different.
He doesn't say sweet peach.
He just implies it.
Yeah, he doesn't have to say it.
Know your worth.
Know your worth people,
check that one out.
It's a good groove.
If you don't like his vocals because
then you'll start to like them.
Yeah, that is your problem.
That's your problem.
That's my rec.
Thank you for your questions.
Keep sending them in.
We'll keep answering them,
and talking about other
stuff, life in general.
Hashtag Ear Biscuits.
You did good.
Where have you been?
It's like she woke up.
He's talking to the dog,
for those of you listening.
Not me.
He didn't just tell me I did a good job.
You did good Rhett.
Looks like you just woke up.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
Don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.